aux états unis après un an à la maison
blanche joe biden fragilisé par la crise
sanitaire le président américain est au
plus bas dans les sondages comme son
prédécesseur d'ailleurs du jamais vu
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale un joe
biden avait promis l'indépendance du
pays face au virus pour juillet dernier
aujourd'hui l'amérique enregistre son
plus fort taux de contamination liée aux
variants plus d'un million de cas rien
qui hier joe biden qui a pris la parole
justement pour tenter de rassurer les
américains vous voyez la correspondance
à washington de notre journaliste thomas
bonnin
plus d'un million 82 mille personnes ont
été testées positives en une journée aux
états unis selon l'université john
hopkins un chiffre impressionnant qui
est toutefois à nuancer parce
qu'évidemment il ya eu un report de ce
décompte suite au week-end de fête qui
vient de s'écouler mais cela veut tout
de même dire que sur les sept derniers
jours est bien plus de 480 mille
nouveaux cas quotidiens ont été relevés
aux etats unis c'est évidemment un
record absolu près d'un américain sur
cent a donc été a testé positif la
semaine dernière le variant omicron
serait responsable d'environ 95% des
nouvelles contaminations selon les
autorités sanitaires américaines et le
nombre d'hospitalisations avoisine
désormais les 100 milles ce qui est tout
de même beaucoup moins qu'au plus fort
de la vague qui a fait frapper les états
unis à la même période il ya maintenant
un an et cet indicateur d admission à
l'hôpital c'est celui qui est surveillé
en priorité désormais par les autorités
américaines anthony fochi rappelle que
même si ce variant omicron semble moins
dangereux que les précédents le nombre
de contaminations très important
pourrait conduire à une augmentation des
admissions à l'hôpital et c'est donc
dans ce contexte que joe biden a pris la
parole ce mardi le locataire de la
maison blanche qui se veut toujours
plutôt rassurant écoutez le vous pouvez
contrôler l'importance de l'impact de
mikron sur votre santé si vous
l'attraper
et d'ailleurs nous avons des rappels
pour toute la nation ok vous pouvez
toujours rattrapé le coc vide mais il
est très peu probable très peu pro abl
que vous tombiez gravement malade et
nous voyons des cas de kobe 19 parmi les
vaccinés sur les lieux de travail à
travers l'amérique y compris ici à la
maison blanche mais si vous êtes vacciné
est renforcée vous êtes hautement
protégé
il ya toutefois encore des sujets
compliqués à gérer pour la maison
blanche d'abord celui de l' isolement
puisque la période a donc été réduite la
semaine dernière de 10 à 5 jours
notamment pour les personnes testées
positives mais qui sont asymptomatiques
on comprend que l'idée est de réduire
l'impact de toutes ces contaminations
sur l'économie américaine et puis
l'autre sujet celui des tests parce
qu'il est très difficile en ce moment de
se faire tester aux états unis on peut
voir des files d'attentes parfois
interminables dans certains endroits du
pays et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement américain a promis le
déploiement dans les semaines à venir de
milliers de tests notamment des
autotests qui seront livrés directement
aux américains des annonces qui
interviennent dans un contexte
particulier et délicat pour joe biden
puisqu'il est au plus bas dans les
sondages et selon les dernières enquêtes
d'opinion il ya désormais plus d'un
américain sur deux qui désapprouvent la
gestion de la pandémie par joe biden